DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
YET ANOTHER STORM IN WASHINGTON
OVER ONE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
NOMINEES.
THIS TIME, GINA HASPEL UNDER THE
MICROSCOPE AT HER CONFIRMATION
HEARING WEDNESDAY.
THE CIA DIRECTOR NOMINEE
APPEARED ON THE HILL TODAY TO
MEET WITH SENATORS IN ADVANCE OF
THE HEARING.
ADMINISTRATION SOURCES CONFIRM
GINA HASPEL IS WILLING TO
WITHDRAW ABOUT THE CONTROVERSY
OF HER ROLE IN THE CIA'S
CONTROVERSIAL INTERROGATION
PROGRAM.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS FIRMLY
STANDING BEHIND HER.
>> SHE DESERVES QUICK
CONFIRMATION WITHOUT PARTISAN
THEATRICS.
THE BOTTOM LINE, ACTING DIRECTOR
HASPEL HAS AN UNPARALLELED
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CIA AND IS
THE RIGHT PERSON TO LEAD THEM
DURING THESE DANGEROUS TIMES.
SHE WANTS TO DO EVERYTHING SHE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THE INTEGRITY
OF THE CIA REMAINS INTACT, ISN'T
UNNECESSARILY ATTACKED, AND IF
SHE FELT THAT HER NOMINATION
WOULD HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
THEM FOR THE AGENCY, THEN SHE
WANTED TO DO EVERYTHING SHE
COULD TO PROTECT THE AGENCY.
AT THE SAME TIME, SHE WANTS TO
DO EVERYTHING SHE CAN TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
AMERICANS, WHICH IS WHY SHE IS
100% COMMITTED TO GOING THROUGH
THIS CONFIRMATION PROCESS.
>> Kimberly: THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED HIS SUPPORT EARLIER.
"MY HIGHLY RESPECTED NOMINEE FOR
CIA DIRECTOR, GINA HASPEL, HAS
COME UNDER FIRE BECAUSE SHE WAS
TOO TOUGH ON TERRORISTS.
THINK OF THAT, IN THESE VERY
DANGEROUS TIMES, WE HAVE THE
MOST QUALIFIED PERSON, A WOMAN,
WHO DEMOCRATS WANT OUT BECAUSE
SHE IS TOO TOUGH ON TERROR.
WIN GINA!"
EVEN PEOPLE WHO USED TOLD US
ROLE THINK SHE'S THE RIGHT FIT
FOR THE JOB.
>> WITH A PRESIDENT WHO DOESN'T
ALWAYS ATTACH HIS DECISIONS TO
THE REAL WORLD, TO DATA,
EVIDENCE, GINA HASPEL IS THE ONE
WOMAN I WANT IN THAT ROOM WHEN
EVERYONE ELSE WILL BE GOING INTO
SAYING YOU ARE RIGHT, BOSS.
GINA HASPEL WON'T.
>> Kimberly: COMING OUT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF GINA HASPEL
SAYING THIS IS THE EXACT PERSON
YOU WANT IN THE ROOM AND MAKING
THE DECISIONS IN THESE TOUGH
TIMES, DEALING WITH TERROR.
>> Greg: I WOULD CALL THAT A
BACKHANDED COMPLIMENT.
WE NEED TO HAVE HER BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT IS CRAZY IS BASICALLY
WHAT HE SAID.
I WONDER, WHAT DO THE DEMOCRATS
WANT?
THEY NEVER WANT AN ADULT.
WHO DO THEY WANT?
DR. PHIL.
APPARENTLY THEY DON'T THINK A
WOMAN WHO CAN DO THE JOB.
IF THEY CAN DO THAT TO
REPUBLICANS, REPUBLICANS CAN DO
THAT BACK.
THIS IS A BYPRODUCT OF TEAM
SPORT POLITICS.
THE OTHER TEAM CANNOT MAKE IT
EASY FOR YOUR NOMINATIONS TO GET
THROUGH.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
QUALIFICATIONS, EXPERTISE OR
TALENT.
THEY HAVE TO DO IT BECAUSE YOU
ARE NOT ON THE SAME TEAM.
THE OTHER THING, THE LONG-TERM
CONSEQUENCES OF STUFF LIKE THIS,
YOU WILL BE PUNISHED IN THE
FUTURE FOR THE BRAVE CHOICES YOU
MAKE IN THE PAST.
HOW WILL IT INFLUENCE
PRESENT-DAY PATRIOTS WHEN THEY
HAVE TO DO WITH REALLY, REALLY
TOUGH CHOICES IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
BEING THREATENED OR IT COULD BE
AN IMPENDING ATTACK AND YOU HAVE
TO DECIDE WELL, AM I GOING TO
SACRIFICE MY FUTURE AND MAKE A
DECISION THAT COULD BE LOOKED
UPON LATER AS ILLEGAL?
OR DO I JUST NOT DO THAT AND
JUST MAKE THE WORLD LESS SAFE
NOW?
THAT'S THE THING THAT SCARES
NAME.
>> Kimberly: SO TRUE.
WHAT ARE THEY EXPECTING, THE
DEMOCRATS.
GOING TO MAKE A CHOICE THAT
PERHAPS THEY THINK IS OKAY
BECAUSE SOMEONE WHO IS PUT IN
CHARGE OF TERRORISM AND MAKING
SURE WE KEEP AMERICA SAFE SEEMS
TOO TOUGH ON TERRORISTS?
>> Dana: I THINK THE PRESIDENT
HAS HIS FINGER ON THE PULSE OF
WERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ON
THIS.
WE HAVE PROVEN THAT AGAIN AND
AGAIN, BEING TOUGH ON TERROR.
JOHN BRENNAN, WHO WAS A SUPERIOR
TO GINA HASPEL, WAS CONFIRMED TO
BE CIA DIRECTOR, AND HE DID NOT
GO THROUGH THIS KIND OF
SCRUTINY.
ON SO THE FACT THAT SHE HAS COME
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES LEAVE
A LOT OF ROOM FOR QUESTIONS AND
HOMES OF THE STRATEGY
POLITICALLY.
JUST A MOMENT TO TALK ABOUT HER.
AFTER 9/11, SHE WAS ONE OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WERE ASKED TO
DO REALLY TOUGH THINGS.
SHE WASN'T THE LAWYER.
SHE WAS THE INTELLIGENCE
OPERATOR.
THE LAWYERS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DELIBERATE OVER ALL
OF THIS, AND THEY SAY HERE'S
WHERE THE LAW IS.
I CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER WAY TO
EMPOWER TERRORISTS THAN TO TAKE
OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN
INTELLIGENCE, WHAT GREG WAS
SAYING, BASICALLY MAKE THEM
SECOND-GUESS THEMSELVES.
SHOULD I, CAN I, WHAT I?
THEY HAD THE LEGAL CLEARANCE.
THEY DID REALLY TOUGH THINGS.
THEY CAUGHT PEOPLE, I DON'T WANT
TO CALL THEM TERRORISTS, LIKE
COLLEGIATE MOHAMMED.
THERE WERE THREE TERRORISTS WHO
WENT THROUGH THE WATERBOARDING.
IT'S NO LONGER AVAILABLE TO BE
USED UNLESS THIS PRESIDENT OR
THIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OR
CONGRESS DECIDES TO CHANGE IT.
THE SENATOR FROM OREGON SAID WHY
HER?
SO MANY WOMEN WHO COULD DO THIS
JOB.
ACTUALLY, EXACTLY HER.
33 YEARS DEDICATED TO PUBLIC
SERVICE.
SHE ASKED TO BE TRANSFERRED TO
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE.
SHE WAS TRANSFERRED ON SEPTEMBER
SHE WAS TRANSFERRED ON SEPTEMBE1
SHE WAS TRANSFERRED ON SEPTEMBE,
SHE WAS TRANSFERRED ON SEPTEMBE2
SHE WAS TRANSFERRED ON SEPTEMBE0
SHE WAS TRANSFERRED ON SEPTEMBE.
DOUBTS HER FIRST DAY ON THE JOB.
I THINK THEY DESERVE A LOT MORE
OF OUR SUPPORT THAN THIS
CONDEMNATION DECADES LATER.
I DO THINK SHE WILL BE
CONFIRMED.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CHOOSING A
REALLY UNFORTUNATE REASON TO TRY
TO PUT HER THROUGH THE RINGER.
LET HER GET THROUGH.
SHE IS GOING TO BE CONFIRMED.
STEVE THAT IT'S A GOOD POINT YOU
MAKE.
SHE SHOULD BE RESPECTED, CHOSEN,
BASED ON THE MAJORITY OF HER
BODY MORE, PROTECTING THE
COUNTRY, WORKING AT AND
UNDERCOVER OPERATIONS.
>> Dana: I HOPE I CAN ADD ONE
MORE THING.
I DON'T USUALLY LIKE TO SAY THIS
BUT WHAT IT MEANS FOR WOMEN
WORKING IN GOVERNMENT FOR HER TO
STICK TO IT, TAKE THE SUPPORT OF
THE PRESIDENT, GO FORWARD AND BE
CONFIRMED IS SO IMPORTANT.
SHE SPENT 33 YEARS THERE.
IT TAKES A LONG TIME FOR WOMEN
IN GOVERNMENT TO GET TO THESE
POSITIONS BUT GOVERNMENT IS
WHERE WOMEN CAN REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN LEADERSHIP.
HER GOING FORWARD, STANDING
TALL.
SHE HAS NOTHING TO BE ASHAMED
OF.
SHE HAS EVERYTHING TO BE PROUD
IT MEANS A LOT FOR WOMEN BEHIND
YOU COMING UP THROUGH THE RANKS
IF YOU GO THROUGH THIS
CONFIRMATION.
>> Kimberly: I DEDICATED -- I
DEDICATED CAREER.
THEY DON'T GET PAID MUCH.
THEY WORK VERY HARD, MAKE
SACRIFICES.
SHE SHOULD BE CHOSEN NOT BECAUSE
SHE IS A WOMAN BUT BECAUSE SHE
IS THE BEST CHOICE IN CANDIDATE.
>> Brian: PRESIDENT OBAMA
COMES IN.
ERIC HOLDER SAYS WE'RE GOING TO
GO AFTER THE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION.
LEON PANETTA SAYS BACK OFF.
THEN PEOPLE SAY WAIT A SECOND.
DOING SOMETHING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ALLOWED ME TO DO TO
STOP THE NEXT ATTACK.
IF YOU READ JOSE RODRIGUEZ'S
BOOK, YOU READ WHAT THE CIA MEN
AND WOMEN DID.
NO DOUBT THEY STOPPED THE NEXT
ATTACK.
NOT ONLY DO I HOPE SHE EMBRACES
HER ROLE IN THE BLACK SITES AND
ENHANCED INTERROGATION.
I THINK SHE SHOULD DO IT WITH
PRIDE.
I THINK SHE SHOULD INVITE PEOPLE
TO HAVE THIS DIALOGUE.
I DID WHAT I WAS SUPPOSED TO DO.
I AM PROUD OF WHAT I DID AS AN
AMERICAN.
I FOLLOW THE LAW.
I AM VERY PROUD OF IT.
FOR 32 YEARS, TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE I AM DEPUTY, NOW
ACTING.
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE ME THE JOB,
DO IT.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE WHAT I DID, HE
SHOULD'VE STOPPED, YOU SHOULDN'T
HAVE ALLOWED US TO DO THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT WAS SIGNED
OFF BY EVERYONE.
IT COMES DOWN TO VOTES.
RAND PAUL, HE WAS AN EYE DOCTOR
AT THE TIME.
PERFECTLY QUALIFIED TO COMMENT
ON THIS.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO VOTE FOR HER.
IF THE OTHERS HAVE ANY HOPE OF
HOLDING ONTO THEIR SEATS IN RED
STATES, THEY BETTER VOTE FOR
HER.
FOR HER TO SAY I DON'T WANT TO
BE RONNY JACKSON ON WEDNESDAY
AND THEN HAVE TO RUN TO THE CIA
TO SAY COME ON BACK, WE ARE
GOING TO FIGHT FOR YOU.
IT SHOWS ME THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
SLOW TO BACK HER.
THEY DID NOT GET THE CAMPAIGN
GOING.
IF POMPEO COULDN'T GET 60 VOTES,
SHE IS SAYING WHY DO I WANT TO
NOT ONLY NOT GET THE JOB AT ROOM
AND MY REPUTATION AT THE SAME
TIME.
I AM HORRIFIED AND EMBARRASSED
FOR LAWMAKERS WHO WILL NOT RUN
TO HER DEFENSE RIGHT NOW.
>> Kimberly: YOU ARE RIGHT.
SHE SHOULD BE CELEBRATED, SAY
WHAT A STRONG, OUTSTANDING
CHOICE THE PRESIDENT MADE, AND
SHE IS WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE COUNTRY FAITHFULLY
DESPITE THE EFFORTS OF THOSE
TRYING TO BESMIRCH HER
REPUTATION.
>> Brian: SHE STOPPED THE NEXT
ATTACK.
SHE WAS PART OF BLACK SITES.
>> Kimberly: WOMEN AND YOUNG
GIRLS GROWING UP SHOULD LOOK UP
TO SOMEONE LIKE THIS TO SAY I
CAN BE ANYTHING I WANT IN LIFE.
LOOK AT THE STRENGTH WHO HAVE
COME BEFORE ME.
>> Brian: IF I COULD ADD ONE
MORE THING, OF ALL THE ACTING
DIRECTOR'S BACTERIA.
BRENNAN, CLAPPER.
LEON PANETTA, HAYDEN,
McGLOCKLIN.
>> Kimberly: LET'S SEE IF
SENATOR RAND PAUL AND
McCASKILL WILL COME FORWARD.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU SHOULD
GET POM-POM'S.
YOU COULD BE THE CHEERING SQUAD.
LACKS COHERENCE BECAUSE YOU HAVE
MILITARY PEOPLE WHO HAVE SAID WE
OPPOSE GINA HASPEL.
WHY WOULD 100 OF OUR AMERICAN
MILITARY PERSONNEL OPPOSE GINA
HASPEL WHEN ALL THE INSIDERS,
PEOPLE I KNOW IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY
DEMONIZED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, NOW EVERYBODY IS
PRO-CIA.
THE INSIDERS LOVE GINA HASPEL,
TRUST OR COME THINK SHE'S
COMPETENT, DENSER DRYWALL.
BUT WHEN YOU COME DOWN TO THIS
ISSUE, IT'S NOT ABOUT HAVING
EVERYBODY ON THE INSIDE SAY
YEAH, WE LIKE OUR FELLOW
INSIDER.
IT'S ABOUT AMERICAN VALUES.
IN TERMS OF AMERICAN VALUES,
SOMEONE LIKE JOHN McCAIN, WHO
WAS TORTURED, SAYS I CAN'T DO
THAT.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN WHO IS
DEFINITELY A WOMAN INDEFINITELY
OPEN TO HAVING A WOMAN, FIRST
WOMAN RUN CIA SAYS THE MORE I
READ, THE MORE DISTURBED I AM.
>> Brian: WHERE WAS SHE WHEN
THIS WAS HAPPENING?
>> Juan: LET ME JUST FINISH
UP.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS A SITUATION
WHERE MARC SHORT AND SARAH